right here paramedics
paramedics
that was the worst thing i've ever seen
in my life that was the worst thing i've
ever seen in my life
somebody literally drove by right in
front of us hit a whole crowd of kids
[Music]
yeah there was kids involved though okay
my mom was trying to help one of them
one of the kids was turning purple in
the
there's blood everywhere
don't be able i'm not
all right
he's fine
i'm sorry no yeah we were told not to
let anyone know
no you're good you're all right man
are you sure that guy was in here yes
yes he was the church
i packed them all in that church that
tall and filled with it
i grabbed them and pulled everybody over
and i packed them
guys i'm not kidding you
a car came driving down the street
car came driving down the street during
the parade
hey
angie
just come here just come here just come
come on
it's okay who's yelling somebody's
yelling something just wait
just wait mom go inside
you'll get inside i'm fine
car came driving right down the street
hit multiple kids one kid was turning
purple my mom was helping him or her i
don't i don't know if he's a guy or girl
but there's blood everywhere apparently
shots are fired but i'm not 100 sure on
that that's what the police say
i heard
and saw
the people being hit but what you could
do more than seeing is hearing and just
that sound was insane
i'm a nurse and my mother-in-law was
saying can you go and help people can
you go and help people so i went out
there
the first gentleman we saw on the ground
um had people by him he was alert and
oriented awake
um so we moved on from him across the
road and that's when
uh we came across the little boy that
was in the road um
turning purple
um
i didn't really have to do cpr on him
but um
i felt his neck for a pulse
and he had one but his
eyes were fairly open and his face all i
can remember is his sweet little
innocent face was purple
he wasn't really with us um it's
waukesha we're a small community this
kind of stuff doesn't happen here you
hear about it but
now that we're hearing the injuries and
stuff that are coming through we all
know somebody or know somebody who knows
somebody you know it's actually a
community so it's just that um we will
definitely i'll be here for each other
um i hope that i can
um see this little boy make it through
it and see him and his family i would
love love to give him a hug
if he's okay